cora's vocal journey was one that i
really really really sat with
with my dialet coach it wasn't just
about sounding like
a person in the times but shaping her
entire story based on the fact that this
is a story of
africans in america and not just african
americans
you know and so on top of that it was
working through her emotional journey
her physical journey and her mental
journey
the one thing that i really appreciated
i think after watching the first
if not the first two episodes one of my
south african
friends was like in complete shock and
the first thing she said was
i didn't know that this is what african
americans went through
and she's lived in america for over 10
years for more than 10 years
and that's the one thing that i realized
upon interacting with the material
and it's something that i think most of
south africa or you know africa a large
uh will appreciate or come to understand
is that we think we know
but then when you when you interact or
engage with the material you realize
that you actually
have no clue and so going into this
process it was important for me to
to come with that understanding that
i cannot dictate or i cannot impose my
ideas
of what i think the story is about i had
to completely open up myself
to learning anew from scratch and
it was barry had sent me a lot of
material to consume
reading material audio tapes and it was
in the audio tapes that something
really stuck out to me it wasn't hearing
the the former enslaved people share
their testimony
that something in me shifted
and went i actually have
no clue at all what it is that what it
is that i'm about to
to um to tell you know and
in that and it was one it's it's layered
in that just hearing them brought out
these
these layers for me in the sense that
one i am listening
to people who are above the age of 75
yet they sound 16. um the way that they
speak they speak a
very broken english that even when um
going through
the the written testimonies with my
dialect coach
i couldn't make sense of what was
happening of what was being shared until
i
i would say it out loud so i could hear
it and it
it it made me understand that the
english that they were speaking
was not english for conversation but
english instruction which is what we
don't see
in hollywood movies today so my
perception of the african-american body
in the 1800s was completely wrong up
until that point i remember i even spoke
to barry about it
and i said barry
they they don't sound like you know
what we think they sound so how do we
find that middle
ground and for me it was really really
important and as much as
we don't want to speak in a way that
would require us to have subtitles
throughout the
story but i was like i cannot totally
disregard
the type of english that they spoke
because it places us
in the space that they were in and also
um
then i i was reminded of
a course that i did in university under
my physical theater course
um part of the curriculum was voice
movement therapy
which is a course that helped us
understand and track
what the voice holds and the certain
traumas that can
shape how you sound in your everyday
life and so for me
korra who comes up as a girl all she
knows is the
life in the plantation she has her
mother and then one day her mother is
not there
and then at some point she is gang raped
by a group of men on the plantation who
then
go out and start rumors about how she
she sleeps with animals and she houses
the moon
and so as a result you know she would
naturally isolate
because now she's ostracized by her
community
and on top of all these other brutal and
traumatizing things that just come with
the life that she had
that she was birthed into you know and
so for me it was important to understand
or showcase or track
how that sounds vocally because again
korra hardly ever speaks
so this chaos and turmoil that is
internal
what does that look like what does that
sound like when she eventually does
open her mouth and as we see when we get
up to um episode nine
uh episode eight and episode nine this
whole idea of have you shared your
testimony
you know so and sharing that testament
means that she has to open her mouth and
speak
so cora's vocal journey was one that i
really really really sat with with my
dialet coach it wasn't just about
sounding like a person in the times
but shaping her entire story based on
the fact that this is a story of
africans in america and not just african
americans
you know and so on top of that it was
working through her emotional journey
her physical journey and her mental
journey
but what really pushed me through was
core's vocal journey
more than anything and on top of
that just understanding her building her
i took a lot of
the stuff that even if it wasn't on the
script
we found in the book and i carried it
over
two book layers of who korra was i have
a lot of notes like
on my personal notes in in building the
character where i would literally put
the page number
of the book so that i could go back and
find that moment so i understand what it
is that i'm doing in that moment in the
scene
well it all came it all came through um
i
i think of nina simone performances
where i'm like my god is she is she
is she giving too much um and and that's
that's what i
honestly i'm being honest and i i know
that barry had um
mental health practitioners and
therapists for everyone
on set as they needed which which is
which is amazing and i'm sure you're all
doing fine but from from an audience
point of view
um i've i felt that there were parts of
yourself that um
were given to us and hopefully we we
will be the custodians of that
performance thank you very very much to
so
um sheila i i have to
um you know with with with your with
with
with mabel with with the character and
with with mental health
and with postnatal and
all the other um traumas that um
i think are encapsulated within within
your story
um how did you feel
you know when people finally got to
understand what went down
um that you you wanted to
project your maple you know
how because having met you and then
seeing the performance i was just like
oh my goodness she again took it to a
place that i'm
i didn't i didn't recognize sheila at
him i recognized this
incredibly caring maternal person that
was born in a time
where all of those um instincts
that she has were were not needed
or were needed but but she had to find a
way to hide them
to help others how did you did you work
your way into this character
oh yeah so i read the book um
at the time which i was cast i don't
believe the the
script for that episode was fully
finished was it barry
so i was like cool i was going to read
the book anyway but i read the book
um and very much in the same way in the
in the
the television series mabel is kind of
threaded through but then there is a
chapter
that kind of explains what happened to
her so that's very much a parallel
that's been carried over
into the show and so for me my my
process was quite self-contained
um in that it's all gonna happen in this
one episode
um and also everything happens in a
flashback so
mine and the rest of the world of the
present of the show doesn't really cross
over
um so for me it was just about i
couldn't really
be too focused on what was happening in
the rest of the show
if that means or my impact or mabel's
impact
in the rest of the story um and so for
me i was just focusing on
mabel's relationship with polly who
is the the character who who gives birth
and loses her child
um and the process was really
myself and barry tracking mabel's
journey throughout that episode so one
of the things that barry said is you
know mabel's got cracks
and we have to just track the cracks
particularly when you're shooting
slightly out of cm
sequence so you know you're having to go
back and shoot something that
technically happened before um and
because that episode
covers quite a long period of time or at
least a lot of story in terms of
time in one episode we had to be very
clear about where we were
jumping to and for me it was just about
seeing the strain
of everything that she was dealing with
not just herself individually but also
the responsibility that she feels as a
midwife again this word custodian keeps
coming up and
you know and people who are caring for
people who are trying to protect
um trying to you know look after
and mabel is certainly a character who's
trying to do that she's trying to be the
glue
in some respects for many aspects of
life on that plantation
um so yeah it was about trying to see
where the cracks were
and what it took for those cracks to
give for the whole thing to fall apart
um and really that that came from the
text for me
um usually when i work on anything that
is absolutely where everything has to
start
and i unless there's a real requirement
to i i try and keep my
process quite simple um unless there's a
requirement to make it more complex
because i
i just want to be able to turn up on the
day and see what the instincts are
but i did of course do my reading i read
into midwifery
during that time to understand more
about what cora's position
as a midwife on the plantation meant
because it wasn't just
she's bringing babies into the world
that also had um
kind of wider ramifications in the sense
that she's bringing
um currency essentially onto the
plantations which is a horrible thing to
um
acknowledge but that's the case um and
also to acknowledge
midwives positions on a plantation
um in terms of stasis you know that was
often a complex thing where
because they were custodians of these
new births
um there was
more space i mean i don't want to i
don't want to misrepresent it as if they
had any you know
um substantial or just freedom
in that sense but they had more space to
negotiate within
because they were important right and
you see her trying to use that space and
trying to negotiate that
um during that episode but of course
it's just not enough it's never going to
be enough in those circumstances
so yeah those were some of the elements
that i had to use to try and
realize mabel but i think the most
important thing
the crux of all of it is that she's a
mother and
she's a mother to cora and in a sense
you know a mother to so many people on
the plantation because she's either
brought them into the world or helped
someone else bring their child into the
world
and is trying to keep everyone alive in
one sense or another
and so that had to be underpinning
everything that kind of maternal
[Music]
instinct
[Music]
you